cata il ne faut pas longtemps à tana et
sa famille pour reconnaître l'appel de
mathieu avec les fortes chaleurs les 18
maki catta du parc de thoiry endroit un
repas un peu spécial pas tous les jours
puisque il faut que ça reste
exceptionnel pour que ce soit un vrai
enrichissement
on va leur donner de temps à autre des
petits glaçons des petits glaçons
composé de fruits et de nectar de fruits
qu'on va préparer à l'avance pour un
petit peu les amuser pendant l'été et
les rafraîchir ouvert depuis l'an
dernier le lémur trek plonge le visiteur
dans l'enclos des lémuriens une
immersion sous certaines conditions
malgré leur accueil sympathique
interdiction de les toucher
si on les touche en fait ils risquent de
perdre leur identité c'est des animaux
qui communique beaucoup avec les odeurs
et en gros si dans une journée il ya 200
personnes qui leur font une petite
gratouille bas à la fin de la journée le
lémurien il va avoir perdu son identité
olfactive est en fait il va stresser il
peut être si exclu du groupe
donc faut éviter cela à tout prix non
loin de madagascar direction l'australie
avec les nouveautés du parc cette année
un circuit parmi les kangourous et une
volière où cohabitent six espèces
d'oiseaux dont les loriquets arc en ciel
bien habitué aux visiteurs depuis avril
ils sont assez proches des visiteurs et
on fait avec eux chaque jour pendant
l'été de nourrissage on va leur proposer
de nourrir les petits loriquets donc
c'est les petits gobelets avec du nectar
et les visiteurs peuvent avoir un
oreiller qui leur montrent sur la main
une visite au plus proche des animaux
surtout des plus gourmands
[Musique]